Một cho việc ngà đã dành lại bàn bộ quên kiểm soát tình tất cả sửa và mẹ gặp
tổng tư lần của nó u cuay nè ông Alex Amdler Kianski ngay một chiến tà bây
vẫn kêu gọi mở chiến dịch tấn công mở ý bảo hai khu vực này
ông Kian Bố tạm của cô học rất tổng thống rất là sĩ chủ chi rằng
Kiai cần khôi phục cá vị trí quân sư và vấn vùng gặng thổ tại hai tình của ngà
sông không như gió kế hoạch của thế
Nông thấy này dễn dạ chào lúc u cuay nè đang chứ up lực lớn và nhìn lực vụ khi vàng ngoại giao
Chân dịch lột kích có sval tháng tạm năm ngoại đã thích bản nặng nè khiến hơn
bởi vì sống như bình xí u cuay nè thương vang theo trên bố của tổng gà bệnh nghiệp
tình. Nông thống năm ông pú tên đã thị sát của bật có sế kìm trà công tác khôi phục
khổ phục khổ chến khiến u cuay nè vẫn tìm gát xuân phà viên giới những trường trường
trang được lại chủ đứng nào. Chúng khi đó các cuộc đàn phản hoa bình dợi kế và mắt cơvà
đã được nối lại từ đầu năm nay tại Istan Buun thổ di khi tuy nhiên ngà tiếp tục nghi ngờ
tình thịt chi của quay nè gà buộc biét tình công bằng ua vê và phản hoa a cơ sở hạ tình dưới sửa
tạm như thành phố trong đó có khu bực cơ sở biét nè.